[Applause]
so yeah so I'm PI mc3 contributor
blogger data scientist consumer of
alcohol um
you can find him twitter with spring
coil and I'm not pitching this but it's
something I've done which is I've put
together a collection of course on
probabilistic programming so if you're
interested you can have a look so I go
to talk about they don't hear me yeah I
assume so so we won't talk by modern
Bayesian workflow this can't be some
like the last two years of doing this
stuff professionally using this library
a lot but also like recent research so
one of the questions that you get asked
whenever you do something a niche and
machine learning world is why would you
do it why not just logistic regression
so my defense of probabilistic
programming or Bayesian statistics which
are used as synonyms is that we have
lots of problems that are small data
problems you know like an airline's for
instance or insurance or finance or
sports sports is a good example or
heterogeneous data problems so like in
pharmaceuticals or maybe even
agriculture so traditional ML models I'm
not gonna quite say xgb sucks but you
know because I would be controversial
but actually Bruce doesn't solve all
problems and these kind of traditional
like best-in-class AML models don't
incorporate domain expertise and they
don't work well of a small data so
anecdotally whenever I was researching
for this court first class this talk and
someone was presented an example where
he did Bayesian model and I got 0.75 a
you see I did a XG Bruce model on the
same data and got 0.6 so I was a
particular like pharmaceutical use case
and I had a lot of categorical data but
it shows you that like you know you know
don't just use one hammer so my kind of
like goal is just talk to you about a
new set of tools now the other reason
this is very important is GDP Ark
happened that anyone get involved are
doing GDP are projects
does anyone want a drink or like current
slang or some sort of likes you know
like we should have like a meet-up just
like that and but if you work with
healthcare data if you work with
insurance data you know finance data
you're you're gonna be working in a
regulated environment we're gonna see
intact more regulation you know largely
because of everything just happened and
but you know but we're also gonna say
that a need for more interpret ability
so one of the defense's off of these
models if they're interpreter will you
get uncertainty you can understand your
high your modest your so we're going to
discuss how to debug Bayesian models
we're gonna use like you know you turn
samplers we're not going to talk about
the underlying engine too much and
that's an entire other course in itself
this is PI MC three specific but the
same principles apply to rania if
anyone's not heard or any irani is owned
by avi Briand the talented scholar guy
at stripe and Stan bugs they all have
very similar ecosystems you know they
have a slightly different languages I
prefer high mc3 because I'm involved
I have no stake in the rest of them but
you're the same principles apply so if
you want some exclusive notebooks I put
together a little mailing list you can
sign up sit up and have a look about
that's gonna be when I what I'm gonna
show they're all so one of the reasons
that's very interesting about the
history of of Bayesian statistics so the
phase is quite an old technique right
days you've died 100 150 plus years ago
I was only really when like you know we
had
okay sorry okay okay I moved too quick I
have a time limit yeah thank you okay
can I go now thanks lobby okay so - so
to handle things like large scales
problems or big data problems in a
Bayesian framework we need to use
Hamiltonian examples these are the
best-in-class samplers they have really
only about 10-15 years old and an
important thing that's very important
tonight Cernik an academic comm remark
is that they only work well under
certain conditions right and these
conditions are often swept under the
carpet so we often ignore why you know
in what cases these things these models
work you know we often say oh it's fine
you know without following these certain
conditions your inference will be wrong
I mean decisions you make on the basis
of any analysis will be wrong so that's
kind of a very important thing sounds
very logical but I think you know in
industrial context we sometimes forget
that whether you like it or not your job
is to inform better decisions most data
scientists don't make decisions we
inform you might think your job is to
understand the truth or whatever but
that's bollocks all science you know
whether it's time and besides the
science part of data science is about
making better decisions so if your
inference is wrong your and your
decisions will be wrong
so let's let's we're gonna quickly go
through Bayesian statistics so a random
variable is a function that converts
random events and here you have random
events two numbers that's all of this a
random variable has a probability
distribution
what specifies the probability that its
value falls in any given interval it
provides the probabilities of occurrence
of different possible outcomes in the
exponent in a discrete case which is on
the Left it's sufficient to specify a
probability mass function assigning a
probability to each possible outcome
it's not so easy in the continuous case
which is on the right the probability
density function describes in fortes no
probability and of any given value and
probably that I come lies and a given
interval can be computed by integrating
the probability density function over
the interval it's very important I've
mentioned the word integrating because
as we remember from from earlier
calculus when we first on calculus
differentiation is a lot easier than
integration so integration is hard and
we're going to learn why we had to
invent these algorithms so I suffered
through graduate school and I need
therapy for that and then you do things
like measure theory you do integrals and
expectations mappings algebra I looked
at this guy there is a really good
introduction by Mike Banner Court which
is here this is link Mike better cord is
a core developer to Stan and general
defender of the pursuit of like good
decisions and great guy and but he had a
has very thorough case studies very
thorough you know case studies and when
he talks with things in depth if you
like good academic writing about data
science it's it's well worth reading
so we have more conventional
distributions they are map parameters
and observations to real numbers
families of distributions are
parameterized by this different input so
once a parameter said
mu and as the standard deviation for
normal it becomes one distribution so so
that we can talk about distributions we
talk about random events with talk about
probability theory here's a very very
quick overview of Bayesian stats so the
key words here are likelihood right the
likelihood here is generally what you're
trying to figure out F 0 is your profit
is your prior distribution that's what
you put into your model that's you know
if you have domain expertise you'll put
that in you may for instance know that
your sales form like something like an
exponential distribution you may know
you know or you may know that Heights
and some kind of measurements that
you're looking at have a normal
distribution I'm the kind of important
thing here is like if you look at the
map you kind of run through the math
very quickly is if you have prior
proportional to likelihood times it's
like posteriors proportional to
likelihood times prior to get that you
need to do an integration and as I
already said integration is hard so why
is Bayesian inference hard because
integration is hard in the same way in
calculus it's harder than
differentiation and this is kind of like
the underlying challenge whenever you're
building bottles for this so we know so
the UM it is an entire class to do like
why MCMC samplers work and all this sort
of stuff but let's just take it as a
given the MCMC samplers allow us to
compute integrals we know theoretically
the MC MC will converge we call this an
asymptotic regime so we will get the
right answer however that assumes that
we have infinite time and infinite
computation you don't have infinite
computation even if you work for Google
or Amazon there's anyone here from
Google around Rizal tonight even if
you're even if your friends or money is
jail and
you cannot have you know em for their
computational time so we have no
guarantee that MCMC will converge you
know in practical computational time so
we need to diagnose our model we need to
like know if it converged or not we need
to know of our models wrongly specified
so there's a notebook and I got link
once you go down I'll have a look at our
through and take people through it um
but the workflow is roughly speaking
build the model your first model will
always be crap your 35th model will
always be corrupt your 97 bottle will
probably be corrupted um be diagnosed a
model by looking for divergences and
then you like your Reaper to meet raise
the model and that's kind of like the
trick thing on the show the general folk
theorem of statistical computing which
comes from Andrew Gelman who's at
Columbia and a course town probably
invented Stan actually is that if your
model takes a long time to fit your
model is pretty specified I won't have a
bottle that took a week to to converge
that was a waste of time and I should
have gone back to be specifying it and
not just leaving it and wasting
computational resources and contributing
to the heat death of the universe but
you that's kind of a thing that you have
to make it like balance
Oh
so everyone see that I'm not gonna do
live coding because that's a bad idea
and I learned from experience and you
can look in this notebook I talked a
little bit the math and the underlying
reasons and justification I'm not gonna
go through this it's too late in the day
um but we we we import our high mc3
stuff and we're going to like talk about
like one very specific example a
specific example is called eight schools
example the eight screws example looks
at SAT scores SAT scores is a you know
it's a standardized test for like high
school students in the u.s. you have
like your mean scores 500 the highest
scoring goes 800 the lowest is 200 you
know their standard standard deviations
but each school had a treatment effect
and like they thought they had a
coaching method and they're they're
coaching effect is like it's a treatment
effect so school a saw they got 28
points more on the SATs from his
coaching example you know it's coaching
um and you know and you can see the
other the other scores you can see like
that's quite that's quite high compared
to everything else so you have eight
schools you there's that one of the
questions is you know what is your best
estimate for the effect of coaching on
on educational performance in these
schools so you consider this this
estimated a fact treatment effect is
wrong and we're trying to build a model
to find a true effect no one argument is
that the best estimate for for school a
is 28 points you can say it's an
unbiased estimate and standard error
what else do you can you hope for but on
the other hand your standard error which
is 15 is large and an estimated effect
in Moses schools so there's something
wrong here you can do the hypothesis
test and
this feels to reject the hypothesis that
the true effect size is same 8 points in
all of the schools so an auditor
argument is that my best estimate of the
effect in school a is 8 points after all
the same course was taught in each of
the schools so each of these eight
schools give me a single estimate of the
CM quantity which it's a course
effectiveness now neither of these
examples is actually satisfactory one
example we've here we've gone like we've
regressed and mean too much we know that
schools are different and if you think
schools is a bit of a like an unusual
example well this could be any category
this could be riskiness of loans this
could be you know different kind of drug
types you know you know like the world
is very categorical in some sense so
rubin who invented this famous example
thought and i think most people agree
that neither of these arguments
represents our state of knowledge the
first argument would treat school a
completely in isolation which you don't
want to do because you're giving up all
your data of your other seven schools
the second argument would assume that
the true effect in ell schools is
exactly equal but we know there's
variation in life so Rubin suggests a
sort of middle path assume that each
school's true effect is drawn from a
normal distribution with unknown mean
and standard deviation and to assume
that observe the fact in each school is
sampled from a normal distribution with
a mean equal to the true effect and
standard deviation given the table books
so it's a lot to absorb it's worth going
through these notebooks yourself you
will get this
my advice is it took me a long time to
get my head around there's eight schools
it does take time one of the problems of
Bayesian statistics is that in much the
same way as deep learning it is
sophisticated it takes time to learn
however but when you get it you'll start
to see examples everywhere and
this is a you know a very good testbed
to just like learn it's like the
smallest simplest problem that needs a
hierarchical model that I could find
that exists in like Bayesian statistics
that's why it's total so you just sort
of build a model so you get your data
you put together your treatment of facts
you put together your standard error of
the effect estimates you basically
translate this here
which is like you're a specification of
your model so theta is your groupings so
off of a of each school mule and tower
like your hyper parameters over your
over your space and why is the thing
that you're trying to model that's your
likelihood function if you go back to
earlier on when we had like like the
times prior equals posterior part I'm
assuming you know me and tau or in some
sense a prior over your your your model
because you're assuming something about
like high scores are distributed it's
worth reading more
there's lots of examples on it the
advantage of the notebook is you get
time to go through these things slowly
but basically you've I've transformed
this from into PI mc3 syntax so for
those of you do not know the pious III
syntax you just basically have a whiff
statement and what into a statement you
just write math so it's you know it's
actually not too difficult to go from
you know an example in the literature to
you know to it like a model so so kind
of the first thing when in any modeling
framework you have a model you're you do
an inference you you see how good your
model is then you go back to the start
you use your the stuff that you learned
to go back to your better model one of
the other things I want to emphasize
which is probably a more general point
than just being statistics is you have
to be very careful with your evaluation
metrics so my first evaluation metric is
R squared
our squared should be last and one
should be about one so it's a size or
half it's similar to our squared
it's a colleague Alvin Rubin said
statistic and we see here this is close
to one we see all these all these values
here are close to one so if we were
naive we would just look at this and say
everything's grunt everything's fine
however if you do more analysis and look
at some of the other things you'll see
here that you know you seem to see like
flatlining here flatlining in any of
these like Diagnostics the the the
metaphor I use when teaching this is
that you should have a hairy caterpillar
on the right it's not very perfect like
notion but it is intuitive so this is
not hairy caterpillar there is something
wrong with our model so there's a couple
other metrics you can use we won't worry
too much about these they are worth
looking at yourself if you want to know
more but this is a Bayesian fraction of
missing information and it's like energy
plots the blue and the orange should be
the same there should be no difference
between them if there is a difference
between them protectee in details the
syndicator
or sampler has a sample very well so
your MCMC sampler has to explore your
space well and has to mix very well um
and the reason that it won't explore
your space well is either you've made it
too short in this case this is a very
short sampler or your space is
complicated and has kinks and curvature
and is you know it gets trapped and
lumen
so furthermore not only some indication
our model is bad we can like look at
divergences and this is all kind of like
built into it so because I know what the
answer should be for this I've sort of
plotted on the graph this is like the
screen line you'll see that this there's
estimation of log tau which is one of
the observations what we're trying to
get doesn't converge so sort of like
hasn't hasn't reached it indicates that
there's something wrong in our model um
I talked a bit more about the geometry
of it but you know you can use these
Diagnostics so here all these green dots
are divergences you know there should
all be red
this indicates that somehow is there
like stuck in some sort of like we call
people call it a phone but you imagine
geometrically you'd imagine like for
example geometrically that you have some
space like this and your your your
sampler circuits stuck there and hasn't
explored all this other space because
for your sampler to give you a good
estimate it has to explore all this
space so here is sort of like God called
in the same way like you have like in
the same way like a gradient descent
algorithm that gets stuck in a local
optimum we can use your analogy from
other things so because our divergences
tell us or something wrong we can
explore like doing different models so
in this in the notebooks I I try a
couple of techniques but we're not going
to talk about them you can look at them
yourselves
the important thing is that you read
parametrize sorry okay so in the norm
centered parameter ization we do not try
to fit the grip level parameters
directly rather we fit a little guys in
variable from which we can recover the
group level parameters the only
difference here is this like theta tilde
here which we applied to our theta n if
we look at the Diagnostics we can see
here that our MCMC estimation along tau
has converged so just by like changing
the shape of the model like we're taking
the model light of your local minimum
you're using this Diagnostics and
forming a better model or you able to
get something nuts like Eliza's do a
rigorous inference about this phenomena
so
oh okay okay there's not really much
more to say afternoon Oh although the
summary points I had were that you
always have to diagnose your model you
Bayesian statistics is usable like it's
applicable to small data problems with
domain knowledge and the libraries are
mature you know there are examples and
use cases all around if you want to
learn more you know probabilistic
programming primer com is a good course
I know because I wrote it and the point
if you're if you're not even thinking
about Bayesian statistics is though is
to think of the larger point of not to
just trust one metric evaluation like
too often we hear over the accuracy is
good and we don't talk about all the
ways of looking at all model we don't
look at precision we don't look at f1
score we don't look at like are more
complicated metrics any questions that's
me
[Applause]
any question for father any frequentist
in the room
yes frequencies yeah sorry so one of the
questions is why how does a scale which
I'm always asked um it doesn't scale
very well like Bayesian statistical
models have got better and you know some
of the samplers have got better there
are other ways of solving these of doing
busy and inference you can use something
called variation inference which is in
most of the modern libraries the problem
of that is that you get a more biased
estimate so you get speed but you you
don't really get reliability I still an
open question about how well these
algorithms work you know they're very
controversial in modern a statistical
circles like there's something called I
in LA which I don't know anything about
but I've heard you know more promising
things about this unfortunately it's
hard to solve everything and you know
small doesn't necessarily mean that you
know you're you're dealing with like two
samples right small can be hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands of
samples but perhaps Bayesian statistics
doesn't work well with millions or ten
millions of samples so it's a it's a
problem of yessir loss
oh okay so Theano is being discontinued
Pym's III the core developers are taking
over it until it's like sunset we looked
at a bunch of back ends and ended up
going for tensorflow probability which
is done by Dustin Tran um so he's
basically ported edward into tensor so
basically google bottom and he works
there
and so now tensor full probability is
very new level
so I've had very little success like I
find a very cumbersome reading and maybe
I haven't spent enough time looking at
it we will be like using it as a back
end I'm currently a lot of the work
being done in PI MC 3 PI MC 4 is to pull
out all the plotting functions so that's
like RV's which is a big project so by
pulling out all these plotting functions
you know it'll probably make the whole
moving to a new back-end easier but I
don't know ie dates off the top of my
head I know I was very surprised with
how quick tensor for probability has
progressed so I mean it's like there's
been like they don't have no u-turn
stompers implemented yet they have alder
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo I'm surprised
that their moves also quick so it's very
impressive so it's like Google seems to
be supporting it in some sense so any
other questions
Oh someone's back do you even like your
phone oh you did
no can't hear you try now I'm guessing
if one was to work through your
notebooks you'd see a series of sort of
divergence graphs and sort of
suggestions of things to try how how bad
is the is there any state aren't leaner
artful otherwise in terms of Auto ml
where you know would it be even sort of
just a reliever you know - revolting
thing to try is the process automatable
at all and and I don't think so at the
moment I don't I don't know off any
coming up with heuristics for like
making better Bayesian models seems to
be a difficult problem because it seems
to be very much intuitive and you know
it and I'm not aware of any olefin mail
can it work like that at the moment
we're still at the stage that we can
like tell you that your model is bad
like and we weren't at that stage a few
years ago there's been a lot of work on
just telling people that their model is
bad and you know therefore you should
yeah
so one step at a time you know we can
maybe someone can come up with an
alternate mal solution but I very early
type it and he any other questions we've
lightning talks die right thank father
one more time
[Applause]